hey 42 here we've all woken up after a
good night out
vaguely remembering something mortifying
that occurred and thought
jesus christ what the hell have i done
but i'm willing to bet you've never
awoken thinking jesus christ why the
hell did i think i was jesus christ
the same can't be said for a small
number of tourists
visiting that old stomping ground of
jesus christ
jerusalem jerusalem syndrome is a
well-documented temporary mental illness
it's been known to happen a few
different ways but the classic
balls to the western wall version tends
to go a little like this
about two days into your visit to the
holy city
one of your group a family member or a
friend
starts to become visibly anxious this is
generally known as stage one
but hey everyone gets a bit nervous
sometimes
it's not anything to worry about is it
maybe not unless he suddenly declares a
need to
leave the group and explore the city on
his own
because this indicates he's entered
stage two
a major warning sign in fact it's at
this point the tour guide might suggest
a trip to the nearest psychiatrist for a
quick evaluation
which may seem a little premature and
heavy-handed
but then your tour guide probably knows
what comes next
stage three the victim will become
obsessed with cleaning
or purifying himself along with an
overwhelming need
to cut his finger and toenails at this
point
it's pretty much a done deal that he'll
move on to stage four
where starts to get truly biblical
after making his way back to the hotel
he'll fashion a robe from bed sheets and
in doing so
progress to stage five in which he'll
start shouting bible verses
or singing hymns loudly and publicly
this is obviously pretty hard to ignore
so hotel employees who've seen this a
hundred times before
may want to shovel the guests into the
back of a padded van
before the inevitable happens he moves
on to stage six
and takes a brisk walk to one of
jerusalem's holy sites
here the deranged tourist will reach
jerusalem syndrome's climax
stage seven and starts delivering an
unorthodox ill-prepared sermon to a
crowd of bemused strangers
needless to say when you ask your travel
agent for a new experience
standing on temple mount with your
bollocks dangling below your bed sheets
wailing the end is nigh in broken
yiddish
is probably not what you had in mind
soon enough the tour group might chance
upon the missing friend
no doubt screaming his favorite verse
from revelations into the face of
some poor passerby enough to ruin any
once in a lifetime pilgrimage
so is there any effective treatment
not really but then it's usually not
needed because as soon as most of the
afflicted leave jerusalem
they're immediately cured which is great
of course
but you'd probably be slightly pissed
off that you've wasted your two weeks of
annual leave
being the son of god there's an old
joke if you talk to god it's called
praying
if god talks to you then you're nuts
and fair enough there is definitely some
comedic value to be had from jerusalem
syndrome
israeli psychiatrist heinz hermann must
have been fully aware of this when he
first clinically described it
back in the 1930s hermann had treated an
english woman he was so convinced that
christ was about to return
she climbed to the top of mount scopus
every morning
with a freshly made cup of tea you know
just in case jc had worked up a first
on his journey down from paradise other
cases of jerusalem
syndrome sound like outtakes from monty
python's life of brian
there was the austrian chef he walked
into a hotel
claimed he was the chosen one and
demanded to be taken to the kitchen
so he could prepare a last supper before
armageddon
or take the american man he became
convinced he was
samson and tried to remove a block from
the wailing wall
still not doing it for you how about the
woman who traveled to bethlehem
positive that she was the virgin mary
and
desperately searching for her baby
jesus if all this sounds strangely
familiar then you may have seen an
episode of the simpsons called
the greatest story ever dode in which
homer is afflicted with jerusalem
syndrome
and in michael moore's mid-90s show tv
nation
a young louis farrow travels to
jerusalem to investigate
there he discovered amongst others john
lichtenberg
previously an air conditioning installer
from brisbane australia
who now spends his days dressed as king
david
singing psalms and vigorously plucking
his liar
and that's not even a euphemism fourroux
also interviewed
jerry a firefighter from iowa who was
now sporting a very
biblical looking beard an equally
biblically looking white robe
and lives in a tent with his family on a
hill
where the apocalypse is supposed to
start because you know
if the end of days is about to kick off
you don't want to be late to the party
not all cases end in the sufferer
remembering he's
not in fact moses but a plumber from
bristol with four kids
a mortgage and a soon-to-be divorce
spouse
some are less fortunate one of the most
high-profile recent cases was of
29-year-old british tourist
oliver mcafee last seen heading off on a
cycling tour
of the negev desert but was officially
counted
as a missing person when hikers found
his wallet
and a laptop along with a trail of pages
torn from the bible
he'd also left handwritten notes
referencing the story
of jesus going into the wilderness for
40 days
and 40 nights as such it was suggested
that this tourist
who was also a devout christian may
indeed have developed
jerusalem syndrome unfortunately he
still appears to be missing
luckily most cases of jerusalem syndrome
are relatively benign
but there are notable exceptions
in 1969 dennis michael rowan was
visiting the city from australia
and became overwhelmed by his god-given
mission to
clear jerusalem of abominations
so it could be cleansed for the second
coming
the following morning he set fire to one
of islam's most sacred sites
the al-aqsa mosque an act which led to
rioting throughout the city
and the rest of the islamic world as far
as india
he was deemed clinically insane and
banged up in a psychiatric hospital
some academics however claim it's unfair
to blame the syndrome on the city itself
and that jerusalem is simply the trigger
for an
underlying mental condition israeli
psychiatrist
yahya bar-el an expert on jerusalem
syndrome
wrote a paper claiming that otherwise
healthy people
with no history of mental illness are
actually in the minority of tourists who
experienced a phenomenon
between 1980 and 93 only 42 patients fit
the category
of regular tourists but then it can be
argued
jerusalem is an evocative place a visit
to the holy city is like walking through
the bible
or the world's biggest budget school
nativity you've got the classic hits
such as
the western wall the temple mount
the church of the holy sepulchre the
stations of the cross
the al-aqsa mosque a combination of
architecture and
history that could fascinate even the
most hardened atheist
never mind a religious fanatic on a
pilgrimage
so it's no wonder this place inspires
those already
teetering on the brink of insanity to
temporarily devolve into a messianic
trance
jerusalem quite simply does what it says
on the tin
well travel brochure the same cannot be
said however for the city that causes
one of jerusalem syndrome's
sister conditions paris syndrome
paris syndrome occurs when blissfully
optimistic visitors to the city of light
are left in dark disappointment after
realizing the reality
of a dirty busy and crime-ridden city
doesn't live up to their expectations of
picture-perfect boulevards
and quaint cafes and when i say
disappointment i mean one so crushing
it actually affects one's mental state
hallucinations
delusions anxiety dizziness
sweating and vomiting are all common
symptoms
the condition overwhelmingly affects
japanese tourists
in 2004 the french newspaper liberation
claimed that over-the-top
representations of the city were to
blame
especially in japanese film tv and
magazines
paris is often depicted as a place where
everyone looks like a supermodel
and gourmet food and fine wine are shat
out of the sky into your mouth
when tourists are suddenly faced with a
littered city full of rude people
the polar opposite of most japanese
cities
the results can be dramatic and
devastating
in 2006 the bbc reported the japanese
embassy
in paris operated a 24-hour hotline
for sufferers to get support but the
embassy has since denied its existence
perhaps tiny eiffel towers and
overpriced coffee
onto your thing maybe you've booked your
next getaway
in the birthplace of the renaissance
well
be careful you don't succumb to florence
syndrome
otherwise known as stendle syndrome
it strikes when tourists are exposed to
artworks
of overwhelming beauty this condition is
named after the 19th century french
author
stendle who encountered it himself when
he visited
the basilica of santa croce where
machiavelli michelangelo and galileo are
buried
he later wrote that he was overcome with
profound emotion and heart palpitations
because everything spoke vividly to his
soul
which sounds like a poetic way to say he
went batshit crazy
staff at the hospital of santa maria
nurova in florence
are no strangers to dizzy disorientated
tourists
who've suddenly felt weird after viewing
the statue of david
mind you aren't you supposed to feel a
bit iffy after staring up at a
circumcised marble penis for several
minutes
or maybe that's just me whilst paris and
florence syndrome
are probably no more than urban legends
and japanese whispers
jerusalem syndrome is a very real form
of psychosis
it pops up again and again in the press
in pop culture
and documentaries and cases remain rife
this is especially true during religious
holidays or at times of
heightened concern for instance the
kaffar shaw mental health centre
which has become the designated
treatment hospital reported as spiking
cases on the run-up to the millennium
in 1999 israel was on high alert
concerned they'd be overwhelmed by
religious nutcases
expecting that lovely apocalypse they'd
been so looking forward to
at its peak about five tourists a week
were admitted with some form of
jerusalem syndrome
and israeli defense forces were
particularly concerned
that someone would try to blow up the
al-aqsa mosque
again we're certainly not going to get a
vaccine for jerusalem syndrome anytime
soon so maybe it's just something to be
mindful of
on your next pilgrimage to jc's
neighborhood
well at least until the real christ
finally gets his act together and comes
back like he's been promising
on the other hand if jesus does come
back then how are we going to tell the
difference between him
and say phil a car mechanic from
manchester
he's just ripped his sheets apart at the
ramada inn
and decided he's going to die for all
our sins
that carpenter from nazareth has got a
lot more competition than he did 2 000
years ago
and maybe that's why he hasn't bothered
to return frankly
it seems like a lot of bother thanks for
watching
you can now buy my new book stick a flag
in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both
in the description below thank you